all right last topic for today john
pascal asks what's the bigger threat to
the chiefs the denver broncos or the la
chargers oh
man
you know oof that's a really good one
because i look at the broncos for one of
those teams to say watch out for it i
think you agree with me i mean you know
again that defense is really good
bradley chubb will be back they got
jerrell casey
they traded for aj bouillier
you know there's some things there you
look at and go wow and of course the
drew lock factor
but i think for right now i'm gonna
stick with the chargers for right now i
am just because it's i guess there's a
little more of a proven commodity there
in that defense they were in the
playoffs two years ago they've improved
their offensive line there are weapons
at receiver you know tyrod taylor's
certainly not as sexy as drew locke to
me but he has taken the team to the
playoffs so you know i really like the
prospects of what denver could do but i
think right now i'd probably give the
edge to the chargers
yeah look i'm excited by what the
denver's con the denver broncos can do
with drew lockett quarterback it was
great to see it late in the year last
year the defense is going to be better
in vic fangio's second season we've
talked about how great pat shurmur could
do with that offense the the arrival of
melvin gordon i i i think the broncos
are a bigger threat i i think that they
haven't been all that far off the past
couple of years and you know like so
many of these other teams you know we
see a team turn it around quickly some
of these teams that turn it around and
go from non-playoffs to playoffs they
weren't that far out of the playoffs in
the first place and you make one
adjustment here one adjustment there and
you've bent the the one loss record in
your favor and i could see them
overcoming the charges i could see them
being the the number two team in the
division this year maybe a wild card
team maybe a real threat to the chiefs
if there's any type of a super bowl
hangover in kansas city i i'm excited
about what the broncos can do now would
i like to see drew lock have the benefit
of a full off-season program yes but uh
i i think he
we saw him get thrust into the fray last
year after he'd missed all that time
with the wrist injury and he was fine
he's got that quiet confidence that
looseness that i think you need to have
in in in a potentially great quarterback
he's not freaked out by the moment he
loves it he embraces it he relishes it
you were all over him last year as a
potential first round pick he slid to
round
and uh i think he's going to prove a lot
of people wrong starting this year
yeah well you know again he's the
perfect example of another guy where if
he came out the year before he's going
to be a slam dunk top 20 pick but he
stayed in one more year the team fell
apart and then everybody viewed them
differently because they we all blame
the quarterback for everything pass
protection whether the quarter the
receivers catch the ball i mean it's
just crazy how we do that but he's
played a lot of football in the sec mike
and you hit on it you hit on all the
right points he does have a very nice
quiet confidence about him and he does
not seem rattled by anything let alone
you and i saw him make a lot of big-time
talents and throws last year and i think
that should excite denver i mean listen
i picked the chargers but i'm with you i
hear you with a lot of the things you're
saying with denver denver is one of
those teams i you know you got to say
watch out for this year in the afc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports